yeah you know the opening hello I'm
gonna stash break you know the rest if
you're like me you're excited that we
get to review commercials again Keebler
Elf oh the nostalgia oh the memories oh
the mass marketing manipulation you
can't wait for it neither can I see how
we call the other episodes after these
messages we'll be right back explanation
point the fourth one and the quickening
this one I'm in titling a Z in it let's
just get to it commercial hey kids
remember when Chuckie Cheese me Showbiz
Pizza disappear under mysterious
circumstances well this is how they used
to advertise on TV the most advanced
video game you can play is awaiting your
discovery at Showbiz Pizza place
actually maybe the reason they ran out
of business is because they put fog
machines on top of their video games for
some reason oh come on I can't see the
princess leave it it also doesn't help
that each game was given one giant dark
room to itself suppose cost-effective as
Willy Wonka shrinking down his giant
chocolate bars who gives a shit he's
playing dragons lame the most gorgeous
robbery of your money ever we lost so
many quarters dis thing cuz we had to
keep reminding ourselves we weren't
watching a movie oh I hope Dirk's
reunited with his Russian Mouse family I
mean damn it I'm playing a game why
didn't this ever become a movie when
that made sense would you want to
explain where that flashing yellow light
came from or the Dragons ability to
learn bubble trapping technology or how
dragon keeps it around his neck Daphne
major testicles drop so fast why didn't
I ever make this a movie with Don Bluth
and his people
what is it flashing yellow lights he's
trying to tell me something
why was i following a yellow light
a simple commercial but simply a tease
what's not to like about it brand new
at Showbiz Pizza place you can have lots
of high-tech fun with Tigers stock boy
tape recorder ah the only good thing to
come out of home alone - that's I have
an even gayer Tim Curry have a lovely
day
the whole movie practically served as an
advertisement for this thing Hey
stop drooling on me hey stop drooling on
me yeah that's what a voice app used to
look like kids in fact that's
practically what cell phones used to
look like - the commercial just shows a
boy playing pranks on his sister that's
cute and all but you got a question a
little bit of the plausibility like the
voice speed control hi kids were home
early
my kids were home early
what creepy as parents sounds like that
is their kid and some friends out there
who really has a father who's like hi
kids I'm about to go slaughter puppies
you stay here and go to bed by 11:00 or
I'll eat your heart
I think I need to be potty trained again
data technology today but kind of cool
back then with a funny if not disturbing
add to go along with it
Tigers talk boy tape recorder comes with
audio cassette as recommended by Peter
McCallister full full is this Christ
lady who bathes like that fully clean me
my ass you're making a bigger mess than
a dog who just want for a thunderstorm
blew this asshole
who's he on a trampoline I'm only two
feet tall don't judge me do I look clean
to you surprise ah wits crowd I'm not
fully clean unless I'm session bully
please this turns a relatively relaxing
part of your day into a seizure inducing
physical strain they'll cause you more
spasms a sponge in an electric chair
look this dude he just wants to take a
nice quick relaxing shower what the hell
does he get oh it's Jim what is
happening
I knew I shouldn't have taken crystal
meth in the morning
speaking of people clearly on drugs yes
fully clean you're not fully clean
unless your zest fully clean my hero's a
bar so by D counseling I don't know why
they have to make getting clean look
like an orgasmic waterpark but I guess
it worked because they're still talking
about it today pretty silly but it's a
camping kind of silly kind of hard not
to still get a giggle hey tomorrow wait
wait where he goes again here's an old
favorite it's a coach trying to get his
team excited to win the big game but an
organ dicing of pasta gets them hyped up
for SpaghettiOs instead because yeah I'd
get a lot more excited for that than
winning a freaking sport oh we gotta be
hungry to win SpaghettiOs what the hell
are they even playing it's a unisex
sport with no uniforms and a game plan
that looks more like a map to bury
treasure no wonder they're distracted by
melted gnocchi they don't even know what
they're playing tomorrow wait wait
however he goes again don't you hate it
when he motivates us for a miscellaneous
sport that we don't like but we signed
up for anyway oh can you taste it yeah
you got it right kids sports are dumb
SpaghettiOs are awesome just like that
controversial Super Bowl last year
attention everyone attention
the game has been cancelled because both
teams want to eat SpaghettiOs
a weird ad for a gross product but one
they'll still stay fresh in our memories
you've gotta be well that was just said
I'll hold you tight Pitambar be a
homebody thought okay I'm just gonna let
you figure things out little girl
there's no rush just you might watch
check out some of these cartoons okay
you just kissed her nipple I'm okay with
being curious but sleeping in pink
potato sacks it's not concept oh look
she sleeps the same way zestfully clean
people bathe though I guess you'd want
to move around too if you slept in a
nightgown that even the Duggars would
call too conservative get ready for bed
bedtime Barbie doll has a soft body
okay I don't want to force any gender
stereotypes or anything like that but
what if this was a boys commercial like
the exact same lines and everything just
you switched out the genders to male
would we really look at this the exact
same way there's a new Barbie I can
sleep with mm-hmm
snuggle tonight bedtime Barbie I'll hold
you tight bedtime Barbie her body side
let's get ready for bed
snuggle tonight bedtime Barbie I'll hold
you tight bedtime Barbie bedtime Barbie
doll has a soft body now with an adult
version for dead okay that part I had it
on but you get the idea what can one say
but naivete my name is bedtime Barbie
vampire Barbie doll has a soft body
wanna come to my place and learn our new
song oh of course
McDonald's is one of the kings of
children's marketing using the only
clown who's a surprisingly slower killer
than Pennywise it's all about hot food
food food
these ads always have brilliant slogans
and catchphrases that would change up
every year or two but sometimes they
were said so fast that you'd swear they
sound a little bit like something else
like listen to this and tell me if one
of these words sounds just the tiniest
bit like something else you know the one
did they just hit or G's to the dollar
menu it's the secret sauce that we're
kin now saying that I'm very
uncomfortable right now you're the clown
and Eyes Wide Shut weren't you
there's nobody here in this this might
be how they did McDonald's at Caligula's
home but not on Saturday mornings
and this is way too unsettling I gotta
find something more pure and innocent
hi I'm Shari the subway guy not bad
Cosby here not bad having pop mmm candy
ah here we go I'm losing weight
deliciously with the aid of aids aids
helps put me in control aids may taste
like a candy but aids contains one of
the most effective appetite suppressants
you can buy ate helped me lose the
weight and has nothing in it that could
make me nervous I think a lot of people
would disagree with you on that question
why take diet pills when you can enjoy
aids I can safely say there are some
reasons AIDS helps you curb your
appetite you eat less because you want
less so you lose weight naturally among
a few other side effects age helps you
stay the way you want to be why not try
AIDS okay dude this came out in the mid
80s where none of you reading a paper so
why don't you let aids help you lose
weight
let the aids plan teach you how to take
off weight and help keep it off trying
peanut butter aids peanut butter aids
excuse me your ignorance has caused me
to retreat into the uncomfortable corner
lose weight deliciously with the aid of
eight now comes was what he colored to
tug at Wow
trying peanut butter eggs okay we get
the bad taste of that commercial out of
our heads
so let's travel all the way to Japan for
one of the greatest ads of all time it's
for the Sega Saturn and to emphasize how
intense it was they created Sega toss
Sun shadow the most aggressive
spokesperson ever it didn't matter what
you were doing if you were off to play
baseball he beat the shit out of you and
say place at her instead she got done
she'll sit alone going out dancing
tonight that noise you're playing Saturn
now say got the Sun Tzu's own Hey look
it's Santa oh shit it's a guitar
first up fling Sega goddammit when he
wasn't pounding the console into you but
figuratively and literally he was
winning soccer games beating skaters
with no skates killing zombies falling
in love and training to his kick-ass
theme song
seunga's hotdogs
this guy is amazing he's like Chuck
Norris fully realized you know like if
you have Chuck Norris I took out the
homophobe stuff he'd have Sega top
he's like a myth they talk about in
story if that myth had a physical
Formica bunchy he was one of the most
phenomenal things to ever hit television
sadly though every myth has to die
yep they actually killed off Sega tah in
the only way Sega too could die stopping
a nuclear warhead from destroying Sega
by jumping off a building propelling it
back with his own feet and launching it
into space it was pretty emotional
Sega pathan sure jamika to me we will
never forget you Sega top will
ironically forget the Sega Saturn it's
not round anymore but you will always
live on he's one of the most awesome
series of commercials ever and I proudly
support a beating of me if it means
seeing more of his incredible
one of the year's most enchanting
stories is about to bloom Oh God
you ever look at an ad for a movie and
say shit I'm gonna have to look at this
for a few months now Don Bluth the
director of an American tale that
director gave us some of the greatest
anime movies of all time says you know
what maybe Barney was onto something a
troll in Central Park
now you two can enjoy the Wonder and
enchantment of a friendship that grows
and blossoms yeah I'm just waiting for
dirt that daring to slice his head off
or the t-rex from land before time to
devour him or the owl from secret of
NIMH to pick his little face out Dom
booth op this da Bluth film and I know
what you're thinking aren't I being a
little too hard on an animation legend
well if he has a problem with that he
can tell me himself Don Bluth
oh my god I am the biggest fan ever oh
my God look at me right now like that
super name he's one of my favorite
all-time movies oh holy shit
americantale and he's just like my
mother right there look to the fucking
leg way before time oh my god before
George Lucas was a swear word I was like
the most unbelievable thing like I want
to kick ass movie about dinosaurs
you are amazing now what are you doing
right now just waiting I want to see
what you're gonna do
what oh I see because I made fun of some
of your working the Patrick giving me
the silent treatment huh okay alright
I'm not gonna be intimidated by film
giant like you you can't give me the
side treatment I can give you the exact
same thing back
knock-knock oh come on it's the law you
have to say who's there knock knock
who's there you go you go who you don't
bye-bye ah well these buttons has to
work hey what's this one do ah suck my
cock a doodle you weirdo hey it's the
most tediously advertise hand darman's
until frozen shops on the fish now you
can be tough by looking like a mix
between a NASCAR driver and Dexter's mom
turn on the TV protect your lap and
sugar anywhere to summon other regions
oh look you even pretend you're the
Power Rangers with this stock footage
just like the real actors pretend
they're the Power Rangers with stock
footage actually the funniest thing
about this commercial isn't even the
gloves it's the alarm you're supposed to
put outside your door get the ball
racially defender the motion detector
that stares off the bad guys oh yeah if
you got bullies at your school that's
sure to scare him away look at that he
hears the sound and he immediately goes
into a seizure I think most of us know
what would really happen in this
situation do you owe your money hey as
long as they don't play let it go I'm
totally ok with these things existing
Sabah's my Norfolk Power Rangers gloves
TV projector lamp and room defender sold
seperately from happiness Express a
Superman trip now you'll tell me why
Superman peanut butter tastes so great
slow day for evil Alex never so fresh
roasted so creamy so yummy that secret
would be mine all mine I needed to make
my ultimate weapon peanut butter aids
the kids save Superman and supposedly
put Luther away in jail but
no as a mirror does this look more like
Rapunzel's tower why do they lock him up
in the same place Bowser holds Princess
Peach also Superman was ready to die to
keep the recipe of his peanut butter
safe
that's some pretty jacked up priorities
there you know Superman it is only
peanut butter never if you'd only give
me the recipe never I've even seen
kryptonite kill a man your insides get
eaten out eyes burst through your
sockets and blood goes out your ears and
knows that you're gonna go through all
of that just for your damn peanut butter
yes you know I'm starting to wonder
which one of us is the true crazy one
here dads like these not Chuck this
super butter isn't still around
just wait Superman I'll find out
Superman peanut butter its strength is
its great taste and the fact that
apparently makes you invisible what what
the hell daddy the devil doesn't a dolt
I insist on a cereal that offers
nutrition frosting I want crafting oh
yeah remember these these were the
frosted mini-wheats commercial that
advertised both adults and kids as
adults and kids
I love the crunchy weak taste of
Kellogg's many weeks but the frosting
side agrees with the little kid in me
the adults would always talk about the
healthy aspects of the cereal while the
kids always talked about the
sugar-coated part of it the proper shell
is low in fat
oh and taste what about Kate the only
problem is if any adult really could
communicate with himself years later it
probably wouldn't be as chipper as they
were letting on I am a very proper adult
so I always eat sugar processed I'm
thinking me energized it's filled with
whole-grain wheat and is so nutritious
for Oh get inside of course if the
younger mean do the scraping off the
sugar side would have prevented it from
being a diabetic he probably one of
eaten it wait what
oh yes and don't even get me started on
your colon that kids have really jacked
up do you I don't want to know this
neither did I but you go through it
along with the next wife a divorce that
costs you most of your earnings
don't forget child support to look after
little brats like you I helped raise I
think I hear my mom calling your mom's
dead
good afford to pay all the medical bills
that you're buying you own the sugar
frosted mini-wheats for your damn little
mouth
do yourself a favor and never grow up
never fall in love never get attached to
anybody in your life you hear me it's
not right it's not do I change your life
before you become a nuclear bomb of
devastation yeah you can escape your
posted mini wheats as part of this
complete breakfast you knew this was
coming someday still a cute idea
even if reality can get the best of it I
know it goes on my tray the sweep stuff
hey little buddy want a ride I was in
college when Pokemon came out so I was
not the right age for it and if you're a
little kid and grew up with it great I'm
glad to have fun but for all the adults
who had to endure this this was a pain
in the ass to put up with it was
everywhere it was like every boyband
except the obnoxious music was replaced
with pika pika pika we didn't know what
it was about and we didn't care we just
knew it was annoying so friggin annoying
so pardon me if I'm not very excited to
watch another commercial on it
I'll be right back wait
my god it's a true are they finally
gonna die
yes squats them to kill them all turn
them into pokey mash the pokey mass
yes
my god that was beautiful I don't know
who you are fisheye lens fat man but you
are my new personal hero where can you
catch all 150 Pokemon get on your
Gameboy that's where table bullshit
fucking cop-out
how do you get a gameboy from a box came
on you know what's strip the power of
emotional denial I will rewrite this
ending in my head the way I want it
smooth where can you catch all 150
Pokemon
Oh happy thoughts
a nice dark idea even if it does need to
go to happy near the end die you're
looking at the next breakthrough for the
Super Nintendo Entertainment System ah
yes the super scope the robbed the robot
of the Super Nintendo okay so your
Nintendo kid and you have a ton of fun
blasting things with your blaster what
do you want this even more advanced than
that well gee how about a shotgun or a
machine gun or a bazooka you ready okay
in hindsight it does sound kind of cool
I mean bazookas make big explosions and
we're all sick fog so we like that but
with those other guns you could be
mobile you can move around you can
pretend you're an action hero who
pretends to have a bazooka what little
kid is like hey you want to go play cops
and robbers
now how much rather play gigantic piece
of plastic I place on my arm immediately
making it sore and sitting still looking
through a little eyepiece I'm gonna hear
about you in the news I yes you are
you're so boring even to look at that
they had to line up a bunch of them in a
row tricking you into thinking it was
more cool than it really was
yeah you know the one thing they're not
doing firing them at the friggin stream
because it's goddamn boring oh wait
we'll do it once there we go
now back to all the exciting things you
will never do with it you might want to
consider some basic training exercise I
know it's like a collector's item and it
has a special place in people's hearts
but there's a reason it never caught on
and it's yours for under $60 price that
sounds like too much even today and it
was a lot more back than give these ads
credit for trying to make it look good
that's another one of those accessories
that just never got them on that - Mindy
- please superscope six only four Super
Nintendo see
it's not virtual boy but it's close
faison you fucking psycho
here's a little PSA from Canada nah no I
wear my lesson Canada is fucked up
they might look all cute and innocent
but then there's knitting in rape
whistles and putting dicks in your mouth
and God knows what else
well I'm not falling for it this time
I'm the sous chef here with any luck I
should be head chef by next year oh well
that sounds kind of nice I got this
amazing fiance
oh well that's sounds sweet a nice
couple finally found love I won't be
marrying this weekend Oh what you had to
change the date or something that's
always so hard when that happens doesn't
about to be in a terrible accident
yeah but really I should have cleaned up
the grease over there and they should
never put the deep fryer so she was
gonna be better no no no no I don't care
what your advertising did you sick yes a
Canada I am never visiting you because
you're scary you're a scary place Canada
put it on your flag you're scaring we're
keeping Michael J Fox you keep whatever
the hell we gave you which is probably
nothing
touchy sack
five four four one more files I'm gonna
say juicy snip oh yeah oh if you're too
young to remember this then you need an
education the idea of having a wrestler
advertise beef jerky sounds as standard
as anything but when that wrestler is
Randy Savage and he's given one hell of
an extreme campaign it turned out to be
one of the coolest ads ever
yeah let's face it when a room starts
shaking it's shit starts blowing up this
is the person you want to see causing it
Romeo Romeo wherefore art thou Romeo
now bored stabbed into a slim jim there
has never been a more pleasing image to
come out of a puff of smoke
he's like the cooling man if he slipped
you ecstasy you just never wanted this
guy to leave on your education guy CAD
own will snap into it ever do a slim jim
look at this it's a room full of lamps
I'm getting hard just thinking of Randy
Savage busting in here
yeah needle Oh Simon
Stefano slim-jim oh my god is there a
way to mate with slim jims
don't answer that internet journalist
place yeah he had so much testosterone
even saying the letter T seems super
aggressive a little tight meant these
are some of the coolest ads ever and so
much of it came from the macho man
himself if you haven't come across any
of these yet then definitely go check
them out here beef curry of spice new
excitement step into a slim jim
telephone chatty
I've been waiting for your call I know I
have so much to tell you damnit share
secret hey girls and we want to talk in
the phone with a toddler of course you
haven't cuz maybe god damn insane what
this exists for some reason wait till
you see when you hide you see us to go
shopping
fucking weird right what are the chances
of finding another girl who likes
shopping we're like soul mates two year
old who seems uncomfortably well-spoken
does she cuz it sounds like mostly
useless shit to me
it's like they're trying to combine
traditional girl stuff to a point where
it makes no sense like hey you like
horses and dresses here's a dress made
out of horses you like babies and
cooking here's how to cook babies you
like dancing and Tea Parties but we
Pride and Prejudice it's an engaging
read of challenging social class why did
these things come together I don't know
it doesn't seem to still be around so I
guess it didn't work some combinations
are clever this one is just odd
batteries not included
okay I'm done I'm sorry I'm sorry about
all the things I said about you just
forgot to say stop giving me that dad
Claire I won't do anything one has
anything at all - for god sakes don't
look at me with those horrible don bluth
the eyes what do you want from me
you
bathtime Barbie doll has a soft body
everybody to Walker here doing the
charity shout out this one you probably
all heard of and there's a good reason
not only is it very good at what it does
but it's also a wonderful idea it is the
make-a-wish Foundation
this is an organization that specializes
in giving kids with terminal illness a
wish that they always want to come true
it can be going to Disney World they can
be meeting a celebrity it can be
anything within a reason that seems
possible there are so many celebrities
and sports stars that have played a part
in this you see them all over either's
videos on it there's testimonials
there's so much good stuff associated
with this place this is a charity that
does everything it can to make these
dreams come true it puts them in a vent
they've always wanted to be and it takes
them to places that they always want to
go
it makes them people they've always
wanted to be it introduces them to stars
they've always wanted to meet this is
the charity you go to to make anything
happen and they are so gracious with
their time they put so much money and
effort into seeing nothing but smiles
come out of these children as with most
good charities they have a youtube site
with tons and tons of videos you can go
through to see all the testimonials all
the wonderful events that they've done
all the fundraising all the creativity
and of course all the dreams that
they've helped come true like I said
you've heard this charity for a reason
because what they do is so wonderful and
you can help bring the dream of a child
to life so definitely click on the link
below and see if you can help a child's
wish come true